[Music]
so
please be seated
graduates honored guests
faculty staff families and friends
welcome
to the long-awaited class of 2020
graduation ceremony
[Applause]
at the stamford university graduate
school of business
two years ago as you prepared for
graduation we went online and cancelled
all in-person events
similar decisions were made around the
world
right around that time
queen elizabeth spoke to the british
people
her theme
as we confronted the growing pandemic
was perseverance
she said
well we have faced challenges before
this one
is different
we should take comfort
that while we may have more still to
endure
better days will return
we will be with our friends again we
will be with our families again we will
meet again
today class of 2020
we meet again
and i am thrilled that nearly 400 of you
are here to celebrate
let's hear it for your perseverance gsb
class of 2020.
i'd like to take a moment to recognize
some of the people here today
gsb faculty and staff
played a pivotal role in the experience
of the class of 2020. could i ask gsb
faculty and staff to stand for a moment
of thanks
[Applause]
we also are joined by families and
friends who have traveled to celebrate
this important occasion
let's turn around and take a moment to
recognize our families and friends
[Applause]
a typical graduation is a moment of
transition we close the door on the
experience of being a student and open a
new one as graduates launch into the
world
precisely because graduates are so close
to being students
it is hard to fully appreciate what has
been learned and what the experience has
meant
today's ceremony is different
rather than a transition let's conceive
it as a moment of inflection
an opportunity to look back on being a
gsb student
and how that experience has shaped your
trajectory
and also to look out to the future
the danish philosopher soren kierkegaard
famously wrote
that life is understood backward
and lived forwards
class of 2020
you are in a unique position to
appreciate what kierkegaard meant
as you sit here at graduation
you have the benefit of two years to
look back
and consider what part of being a
student
opened your mind
changed you
influenced your choices
i expect that many
specifics have faded
a haze has settled on the details of a
cruel accounting
simulation modeling
how much you paid for the furniture in
your past dan house
instead
moments of serendipity take on larger
meaning
an illuminating common in a class
a memorable speaker
a conversation that ignited a friendship
i also hope
that as a result of your gsb experience
you think more clearly about decision
making
strategy
organizations
i hope you've built on the foundation of
leadership skills you developed
i hope the relationships you formed have
become stronger
and i hope returning this weekend
provides an opportunity to reflect on
this
when kierkegaard wrote that life must be
lived forward
he meant that not everything could be
anticipated or planned or understood in
advance
sometimes you just have to make it up
you learn that lesson in your final
quarter at the gsb
you started non-profits to source
medical surprise supplies
you organize dozens of virtual events to
maintain a sense of community
you work to address racial inequality
you were generative
in the face of bad news and uncertainty
you figured out how to create
had a build
even had a contagiously spread
positivity
we've watched you carry that into your
careers
if today's graduation is an inflection
point we should recognize that we are
also at an inflection point in the world
we are gradually emerging from two years
of pandemic
the world has changed and we face urgent
challenges
in my final message to you in june of
i quoted president franklin roosevelt
who in the great depression told the
graduating class
yours is not the task of making your way
in the world
but the task of remaking the world
which you will find before you
that still resonates with me
as you renew your stanford ties today
and relaunch
remember that each of you has the
capacity not just to make your way
rise high
build in a way that raises others
set yourselves the task of making a
better world around you
welcome back to stamford and
congratulations
now it's my great pleasure to introduce
our speaker orlando bravo
orlando was born in puerto rico as a
teenager he became a nationally ranked
junior tennis player
at one point even roomed with the future
world number one jim currier
he went to brown university
and after a short stint on wall street
came to stamford
he earned both an mba
and a jd from the stamford law school
orlando went on in finance and private
equity and in 2008 he founded tomah
bravo with fellow gsb alum carl toma
under orlando's leadership tomah bravo
has become a leading software investment
firm
and a few years ago forbes magazine
called orlando wall street's best deal
maker
orlando returned to puerto rico after
hurricane maria in 2017 to lead
humanitarian work
since then the bravo family foundation
has focused its efforts on creating
opportunities for young adults in puerto
rico
orlando is a trustee of brown university
and a great supporter of the gsb and as
you are about to see his brilliance and
his energy are legendary
please join me in welcoming orlando
bravo
yes
gsb class of 2020 huh
let's go
seriously
by the way that's something that i say
when i'm really fired up so remember
that because i'm going to ask you to say
it at the end
okay and i'll be brief
but i'm really so excited for all of you
you're here together you are the
absolute best
of your generation
and you have come together here to
celebrate
as fellow members of our very close
gsb
alumni family
now
i'm going to talk to you from the heart
because i know no other way
to really address you and really talk to
you it is so meaningful
for me to be here with you today
because stanford has had such a profound
impact
on my life
the gsb
is the place that gave me the courage
and the confidence to think big while at
the same time encouraging me to
celebrate my past
so here i am with an incredible chance
to speak with all of you and i want to
thank dean levin for giving me this just
incredible incredible opportunity
i'm going to tell you a brief story
of how i got to stanford
and and the purpose
of my story is that i think it best
exemplifies
the culture here at the gsp that all of
you represent
exactly 30 years ago i got into stanford
yes
i did
and i also got into some i'm just going
to say it east coast school
right at the same time
now
late
in my decision making process
i was able to get this job i didn't know
i was going to get this job offer but i
got it and i really wanted to do that
for a couple of years before coming to
business school
so i first called the school on the east
coast to see how they would feel about
me deferring a couple of years
and their answer was really clear
absolutely not
if you don't reply by this date you will
lose your spot
and if you would like to come years
later maybe you should apply again
with my hopes down
i then called stanford
and on that call the head of admissions
just happened to be in her office she
picked up the line
and i scrambled to start making my case
and as i did she stopped me and she said
orlando you can come to stanford
whenever you want
we will always have a place here for you
just give us
about six months advance notice
and let us know when you're ready
wow
i i will forever be grateful for that
for that call
stanford welcomed me with open arms and
even before i set foot on campus
stanford was encouraging me to do what i
wanted to do
and it was opening big doors for me
now i share this story this is a good
one for me
but the point of me sharing that with
you is on that call the head of
admissions at the time
exemplified three key traits
from your culture our culture here at
the gsb
first
she was a real person
she spoke to me like a real person she
was genuine she was authentic
two
she was relaxed
she was casual
and third
she was focused on me being ready
my goal today
is to inspire all of you
to carry with you throughout your
journey these three key cultural
straight traits of stanford of the gsb
number one
be real
number two
stay relaxed
and number three
be ready
okay
let's talk about being real for a second
when i first came to the gsb
i knew i was coming to the place with
the absolute best classmates
and the most impressive scholars
but little did i know how much fun
this place would be
okay
we found roommates and i lived with
seven of them and we became best friends
by the way they're here in the crowd in
very special seats
um after after many years and we threw
one party after the other i am sorry but
we did
okay we would go to cabo and i believe
it was my class
and i believe it was my class that
started a tradition of trying to rally
as many people as possible to go to
vegas
[Applause]
now
i also understand that all of you have
upped your game
and now the entire class goes to vegas
which proves one of my theories that the
younger generation is always better than
the prior
but anyway within this
stanford
combines an environment in the gsb of
the best of the best while at the same
time a very fun and casual place
and that in itself is such an important
lesson in leadership and in life
think about it you can be the highest
performing individual
while staying real
while staying authentic
while being yourself
and when you do that your personal story
will shine so much better
and it will for sure make you
a much much much better leader
number two
sorry that i have to drink water i'm
getting fired up about this
number two
i want you all to work really hard
in staying relaxed
there's so much pressure now
in being calm
you're the best
why worry so much
really
[Applause]
when i when i graduated
from the gsb in 1998
i got my dream job a dream job in
private equity i've been trying to get
into the industry for a long time
but then i proceeded
to set strict deadlines on my progress
i put just incredible pressure
on myself
i worked so hard
and three years later i had absolutely
nothing to show for it
except for bad deals
that were all going to zero
they really were which was a disaster
and i was about to be fired
at the same time
my first daughter was being born
i remember this like yesterday
and i'm there at the hospital
and i'm thinking i forgot to buy diapers
so i rush over to the marina safeway and
by the way for all of you that live in
san francisco please don't go to the
marina safeway to buy diapers you go
there to meet people it's an excellent
environment for that but don't go there
for that
so so i find myself in this i guess
diaper aisle
thinking what did i do
what just happened to me
from the days of the gsb of thinking big
of going to vegas
with my classmates to now
about to get fired
completely unprepared to have a child
and fumbling through a diaper aisle here
at the marina safeway
and then
i promise you something switched for me
i started laughing
i accepted the moment
i let it go
it all changed i relaxed i calmed down
two weeks later
i go back to work
and my mentor carl thoma also a gsb alum
one of the greatest of all time
he sits me down and he said i'm going to
give you a second chance
i was calm i was relaxed i was at peace
and that gave me clarity it gave me
purpose
and it allowed me to do my job with my
own personal style
that resulted in less bad decisions
in better outcomes
and it was a better journey
so for all of you with all the pressures
work hard really i would encourage you
work so hard to stay relaxed it will
give you clarity it will give you
purpose it'll be better for you and
you'll be a better leader as well for it
and finally gsb class of 2020
be ready
okay the world will call upon you to do
something
very important
you're the best that means you will be
afforded a good journey
but because you're the best you'll have
a big responsibility
and you cannot
opt out out of that responsibility
for me an important moment came in 2017.
i was coming back from a fundraising
trip in asia
and as the flight was going hurricane
maria hit puerto rico
when i landed i knew things were really
really bad
i could not get in touch with family i
cannot get in touch with old friends i
get home and i'm glued to the tv
listening to a lot of reports
on how aid was not coming to the small
towns right where i grew up in because
of logistical issues
the only communication that i got during
that time was from a reporter that said
there was a shelter
near where i grew up that had just 24
hours of food and water left
and that's when i knew i had my call
at that moment that was a call for me
because if i didn't do anything about it
no one would do anything about it
now i didn't know anything
about hurricane relief
about supply chains i do software
about logistics
i didn't have any contacts in the
government of puerto rico i didn't have
any contacts with community
organizations puerto rico i lived in san
francisco i had friends and family there
but the gsb taught me to take risk and
to not be afraid of failure
so we started a relief operation gsb
style
it was entrepreneurial
it was practical
it was immediate it was results oriented
and within roughly 10 hours of that we
had communicated back to the reporter to
say we'll be there tomorrow
we had filled up this plane with as much
food and water as we could get
and we head off to puerto rico
and when we landed
this man opened the door doors of the
plane with fear in his eyes
as if to say i can't believe somebody's
here
the place was completely deserted
and then i looked to my left and on the
road there were three trucks
they had made it
we had made it
and that's when i knew i made the right
call
now that was my call you will get your
own
and i'm really really grateful for the
gsb
because it led me to think
that this incredible place didn't just
train me to be a private equity
professional it trained me for bigger
moments like this one
i want to end by saying that the gsb has
given you a foundation to solve
some really really big problems
once again you will be called upon
to do something really important
and to do something that is very
personal so it is for you to do
you don't have to go looking around for
this event
or what this moment is it will come to
you
for some of you that's already here
for some others the moment will come a
little sooner for some other the moment
will come later
but i promise you you will know
exactly what that moment is
and you will know exactly what to do
and when that happens you have to go all
in and you have to give it all you have
so
gsb class of 2020 i am extremely proud
of all of you
you will accomplish
incredible things much bigger than those
of your mentors
for now
remember
and really really remember
be real
be relaxed
and be ready
and with that i want you to repeat it
with me
gsb class of 2020
where we say let's go one two three
let's go okay there we go
[Applause]
thank you so much orlando that is a very
tough act to follow
um good afternoon i am so delighted that
we have set this up so that the friends
and family can get the full experience
of the gsb by sitting in the back with
several empty rows
between them and the speaker
that was a stroke of genius
it is my pleasure as director of the
stanford msx program
to present the 2022 graduate 2020
graduates who will receive the degree of
master of science in management
it is so great to see you all back here
and thriving when we last saw you the
pandemic was just getting going and many
of you faced incredible challenges here
at stanford and with your families at
home
you finished the
program under a cloud of uncertainty and
we're so proud of what you've all
accomplished in the intervening time
the mission of the msx program is to is
to provide experienced leaders men and
women who have spent at least eight
years in professional and management
roles the opportunity to prepare
themselves for increasingly senior
positions in organizations they will
lead
msx students participate in a full-time
year-long course of academic study
giving these students an all too rare
chance for reflection and growth in the
midst of an already accomplished career
on behalf of the administration of the
program and the faculty who have taught
them join me in wishing each of them
great fulfillment and success in the
next phase of their careers
in honor of the service of former gsb
dean robert joss who was himself a
student in this program
the top 10 of the msx class ranked by
academic performance are designated as
robert joss scholars
as we read the names of the graduates we
will also announce if they have achieved
the distinction of robert jost's scholar
margaret hayes associate dean of the mba
and msx programs will now read our
graduates names while dean levin
presents the diplomas
maya dear
jeremiah kareem adams
[Applause]
kingsley offer mickey robert josh
scholar
eric marquardt
robert josh scholar
gregory maurice anwar barrow
niraj biani
gonzalo blanco estades
lauren rachel boros
kevin boyle
matthew william brown
daniel carroll
elisa chandler
[Applause]
elizabeth mcpherson chapman
sandy chapman
[Applause]
lamia lauren dave robert josh scholar
pratheeba david
matthew davis
anupriya davidi
charles avislaj
[Applause]
j finch
renato flo
abhishek garg robert josh scholar
[Applause]
matthew garrison
kumar gotham
[Applause]
oliver hayward young
thomas kevin higginbotham
[Applause]
robert josh scholar
lisa marsh levin
[Applause]
olga mathuikova
travis melvin
kayore myth
[Applause]
david moyes
kaushik nara simon robert josh scholar
wakar nayer
nikki panitch
nianwei nina cho
[Applause]
vijay raghunathan
amit ravil
[Applause]
andrew lee rubinger
ayla soleil schlosser
hannah chevalava
stefan johann robert sputzier robert
josh scholar
vikas srivastava
june sudo
yuval tamir
[Applause]
v piani
alejandro villalobos
lisa ward
[Applause]
justin wong
shiya masahiro yamamoto
takaomi yukawa
[Applause]
rick zhang
among among the robert l joss scholars
one student's academic achievement
places them at the top of the msx class
this student is awarded the george c
parker prize named in honor of gsb
faculty and former program director
george parker who is here today george
there he is
the graduate receives a certificate a
cash award and their name will be on a
plaque displayed at the gsb
the recipient of the george c parker
prize is abhishek
garg
please please
please stand
please
there's abi shaq please stand and be
recognized great thank you very much
congratulations
[Applause]
i am now going to move on to the mba
class
[Applause]
[Music]
distinguished guests faculty staff
family and friends
mba class of 2020 welcome back we missed
you
you finished under extraordinary and
difficult conditions and it's great to
have this opportunity to properly
celebrate your accomplishments
the mba students gathered before us
today engaged in a transformational
experience
they acquired solid foundations in
general management and have pursued
deeper study in the areas of interest
they engaged in personal growth and
built relationships that will last a
lifetime
they have helped the school and the
community in many ways
while their experience here required
navigating the challenges of a global
pandemic that changed classes and other
activities in countless ways they
persevered and formed bonds that i
expect will be stronger than the mba
classes that came before them
they're an impressive group and are
ready and worthy to join the ranks of
our illustrious alumni
therefore it is my great honor and
privilege to present to you the stanford
mba class of 2020.
i hope your memories of the gsb have and
will continue to remain fresh and that
you will stay involved with the school
our alumni played an important role in
your academic experience ranging from
serving as judges in the executive
challenge to acting as mentors and
entrepreneurial courses i hope that you
too will engage with gsb's academic
mission as alumni and give your time and
experience generously to future classes
you will leave your own legacy and play
a part in bringing the gsb experience to
future generations as other alumni have
done before you
on a somber note i would like to take a
moment to remember your classmate erica
pincus who died last june
in 2020 erica earned her mba from the
gsb and an mpa from harvard's kennedy
school
it is heartbreaking that she is not here
with us today but we are grateful to be
joined by her parents and her close gsb
friends to honor her memory
[Music]
so
there is a picture of emma in the
program
and a seat among the graduates which is
marked with a red ribbon that would have
been hers today
thank you for honoring her that way
all of you here have undoubtedly heard
of rj miller rj served in the u.s air
force during the second world war and
was later one of the so-called whiz kids
who revolutionized ford motor company
rj became president of ford
and then later the much admired fourth
dean of the gsb from 1968 to 1978.
in honor of dean miller's service the
top 10 of the class ranked by academic
performance are designated as rj miller
scholars
as we read the names of the graduates we
will also announce if they have received
the academic distinction of r.j miller
scholar
in the case of joint degree students who
are walking today but not graduating we
will identify those who are currently in
the top 10 percent of the class
the late dean miller also founded the
certificate in public management and
social innovation program at the gsb
the certificate program educates leaders
who understand societal issues design
for and evaluate impact and understand
the specificities of the management of
social organizations in both the private
and the public sectors
today's certificate graduates take the
spirit of our gsb motto change lives
change organizations change the world to
its full potential
we have 119 recipients in the class of
2020 their names are listed in your
graduation program
graduation names will now be read by
kirsten moss assistant dean of mba
admissions
and financial aid and by jamie shine
assistant dean of the career management
center
graduates will receive their diplomas
from dean levin
kirsten and jamie would you please begin
samantha abrams
pulket agarwal
marissa bell agusto
andrea aguirres ruiz
[Applause]
mo dupe akinawano
[Music]
[Applause]
eduardo alvarez de toledo pinard
spencer apremian
jack armstrong
andreas assad kotner
patrick timothy atwood
christopher barnum
[Applause]
luciana rossi barrancos
hannah barrett r.j miller scholar
[Applause]
now
michelle baumgardner
[Applause]
lexi bloat rife
monica beltran
[Applause]
ellery burke
cj bernstein
[Applause]
a
otis blum
etta bora
[Applause]
maya boutros
shelby anne brager
[Applause]
william james brooke
timothy francis brown r.j miller scholar
eduardo sideko boise
[Applause]
emily carroll r.j miller scholar
matthias castillo
emily nunez kavnes
ryan j
chan
mindy chang
arnab chatterjee
josephine chen
[Music]
rafael
peter gallen cohen
rebecca b
colby
dario constantine
[Applause]
caleb craigle
jorge quetto
carl johar
r.j miller scholar
[Applause]
madeleine dean
jaime castillo ojero
caroline dewing r.j miller scholar
benny dear
emilio diaz
song
[Applause]
andrew dodds
i l donut zafir
[Applause]
jane dong
megan diane downey r.j miller scholar
adam drooks
[Applause]
robert dunleavy
kevin durkin
[Applause]
chingis jumana zaroff
heather michelle eaton
[Applause]
maria
gomez
nicholas elledge
[Applause]
cepha erdogan
izzy ernst
[Applause]
tyler ernst
[Music]
hans falkinger
alexandra farhat
[Applause]
genado toledo varilla
lynn farrow
[Applause]
william faulkner
jordan alexander feiko
[Applause]
ian andrew llewellyn field
jill fisher
[Applause]
bowen eric fuchs
khalil fuller
sofia garces
sebastian garcia
[Applause]
[Music]
travorsky garrett
toby gerhart
[Applause]
luisa catarina gosnell
renata giriola
[Applause]
matthew gibstein
ida noel girma
[Applause]
adrian kai guthuku
emily gittins
[Applause]
george matthew c go the second
patricia cochicoa sanchez
[Applause]
danny gold
ashrat goldberg
maya granite
khalil grell
charishma grover
[Applause]
javier ginard
isaac ashman hails r.j miller scholar
hamm
lad hamrick
[Applause]
tom hansen
lowell graham hayes
[Applause]
tara hill
jane rebecca hinkle
[Applause]
lachen ho
grace horowitz
[Applause]
when how edwardship
lucia wong
[Applause]
[Music]
molly and adomi
[Applause]
jagtiani
hersheta nirmal jen
[Applause]
darren jakolev
andrew jakubowski
[Applause]
isabel james
christopher jane
[Applause]
akil arvind jerry walla r.j miller
scholar
derek johnson
casey jones
[Applause]
david uttershaw
[Music]
[Applause]
nathaniel cainfield
aaron cappy
[Applause]
jonathan kaufman r.j miller scholar
jacob chemet rosenwald
[Music]
david cavari r.j miller scholar
christine kim
[Applause]
j kim
grace kin
alexander cannon knight
[Music]
habla ko cj
[Applause]
alexander cray
phillip krinner
kelly michelle lacob
[Applause]
caitlyn jeannie lang
carla laron
[Applause]
ruth lawinson
evan lee
[Music]
[Applause]
kate lee
timothy shin ching li rj miller scholar
benjamin leff r.j miller scholar
daniel levine
ben levison
[Applause]
emily winston levy
anna guadalupe leyva
beijing lee
maxine
king t lim
rich lim
[Applause]
shing lin r.j miller scholar
cheryl lou
eric lou
[Applause]
ran lou
corey longhurst r.j miller scholar
olivia lopez balboa
[Applause]
megan w lew
kevin lubega
[Applause]
julie mackelberg
[Music]
[Applause]
johanna maldonado
[Music]
[Applause]
colton mulkerson
tyler maloney
[Applause]
rohan menchunda
dan mandelbaum
[Applause]
imogen mansfield
eleanor hodgson mancilla
[Applause]
sam margot
hugo martinez
daniel mcdermott
[Applause]
yannick meyer rj miller scholar
sebta mehmet
zubair meme
julia milch
marta miazkovska
[Applause]
haley miller
kyle mills
bradley john mitchell
lucy margaret montgomery
[Applause]
michaela ruth moore
neni morehead
possum matlog
[Music]
[Applause]
diane diana hassan musa nassar
heather nguyen
roy nikolay
[Applause]
tamir nisbet
nathan nola rj miller scholar
tomak navinsky
[Applause]
madison obiedo
lay oh
[Applause]
chisholm acappala
holado
[Applause]
jorge holarte blanco
peter olsen r.j miller scholar
valerie osbend
[Applause]
andrew ovid
carla puccini
[Applause]
peggy penn
[Music]
[Applause]
peter paris
[Music]
judy park
[Applause]
sam parker
thomas robert paddock
[Applause]
priyantan pavala nathan
boucher pierre
[Applause]
andre
sorry andrew pinelli
prashanth
[Applause]
bruno paleto
ross pomerantz
[Applause]
andrew henry powell
bonner campbell price
alexander
prop matthew prusak
[Applause]
annie chin
fabiola quinzanos
vikram ramakrishnan
sangeet ranjan
carlton perano rawls
[Music]
edward redden
julia rachelstein
stein
yen faye wren
danny reyes
[Applause]
yama resende
benjamin greer rhein
[Applause]
samuel rieber
stephen rickley
felipe rodriguez r.j miller scholar
[Applause]
gum roland
gal ron
gregory rose
[Applause]
itan
vo ravero shane
[Applause]
andrew rubinstein
victor alan rudow
stonebrook ranco
[Applause]
marcus rush
lindsay sacaleris
[Applause]
san martin
r.j miller scholar
[Applause]
pedro salgado
michael monroe saltzman
[Applause]
maxim zapposnikov
alexander sappington rj miller scholar
sid sepuru
christopher lord saturday
taylor savage
[Applause]
alicia sayal
aj scaramucci
[Applause]
carlos fernando scheckman
david blair schmidt felner
[Applause]
robert schneider
kimberly schreiber
[Applause]
nathaniel siegel r.j miller
scholar timothy seminov
roberto seminario
austin
settle
[Applause]
kavya shunker
jess
simpson
[Applause]
angela rae sinistera woods
rj miller scholar
[Applause]
joey scavernak
elise smith
cleo cecilia smuro
charlie spokes r.j miller scholar
katarina orrique
stiegelroner r.j miller scholar
tara drewding
[Applause]
alvaro stelovich ross
jack strabo
[Applause]
carolyn strawn
karen sun
[Applause]
carl lawrence smutko
sammy teleton
[Applause]
allegra tepper
katya
katya tehran
[Applause]
natalya chowdhry talker
jason topol
[Music]
[Applause]
michael ian topol
duke tuantron
[Applause]
trevino vargas
christina troitino
allen c r.j miller scholar
chloe sang
[Music]
[Applause]
selena tyler
casey ohlinhoot
juan antonio valdez guzman
[Applause]
william vallory
[Music]
moritz vanderdonk
[Applause]
igor vasilaki
david vasquez
[Applause]
maria andrea
via real
science
[Applause]
claire alexa wallock
chi jenny wang
[Applause]
eileen marie wares
zoe weinberg
[Applause]
christopher todd williams r.j miller
scholar
alexis sterling wise
[Music]
[Applause]
michael wishart
emma marion wood
cyron shu
[Applause]
[Music]
r.j miller scholar
[Applause]
bar your own r.j miller scholar
bella monya you
ryan yura
[Applause]
vincent you
diego zavala
julia zhang
[Applause]
megan elizabeth zinke
maximilian zala r.j miller scholar
nominated and chosen by their peers the
recipient of the ernest c arbuckle award
is a second year mba student who by
their active participation
initiative leadership and personal
integrity is judged as having
contributed most to the fulfillment of
the goals of the stanford graduate
school of business in their actions both
within school and society
the recipient receives a cash prize and
also has their name on a plaque on
display at the gsb
we are delighted to have susan arbuckle
the daughter of ernie arbuckle with us
today
the nba class of 2020 arbuckle award
winner is ryan yora please stand
[Applause]
foreign
i really enjoyed the procession i had
some great flashbacks to a trip to
beijing with many of you a few years ago
that was that was great um the alexander
robicheck
student achievement award in finance was
established to honor professor
robicheck's outstanding contribution to
the teaching of finance at the gsb from
1960 until his death in 1978.
the award is given
to an mba student selected by the
finance faculty for outstanding
achievement in their finance courses the
recipient receives the award and also
has their name on a plaque on display at
the gsb
the nba class of 2020 recipient of the
robocheck award is timothy francis brown
variant congratulations
and finally among the r.j miller
scholars one student's academic
achievement places them at the top of
the class this student is designated as
the henry ford ii scholar and receives
along with the miller scholar scroll a
significant cash award and their name on
a plaque displayed at the gsb
the mba class of 2020 henry ford ii
scholar is nathaniel siegel
honored guests faculty staff families
and friends we have reached the
conclusion of our ceremony
in a moment i'm going to ask all of you
to join us for a reception just outside
the gates of frost
class of 2020 will you please rise
in the spirit of what orlando said
earlier i'd like everyone to join me in
one final class of 2020 let's go
one
two
three class of 2020 let's go
congratulations class of 2020
you may recess from the amphitheater
[Applause]
[Music]
world
you